[Laughter]
oh that's noisy
let's mute that it is muted okay am i
live
it always takes me a long time to figure
out
[Music]
i think i am all right
are you guys ready to play a video game
oh absolutely
what are those like what are they get
out of here
okay we're going main show am i going
host custom
nope that one i'm gonna be the first
person
i'm hiding my game capture and i'm going
home
submit okay and i need to
show code it is not being broadcasted it
is not
okay okay it really is right there
i have so much anxiety that i'm going to
be the one that accidentally
and then don't do it here's the thing
that i didn't tell you if that happens
i block you on twitter and never speak
to you again
that sounds like a benefit
[Laughter]
i just broke out into a sweat
okay here we go oh wait you're now
getting sweaty i've been sweaty this
whole time
i've been sweating the whole time hello
everyone
who is watching the stream we are
raising money for thanks today
end child poverty i'm in um
now good luck this is super chaotic it's
going to be a great time
we have uh 60 60 streamers i will be
jumping through different
servers to play with these people it's
going to be nice it's going to be nice
we have code friends we have code
everybody ready it will
it's not sure wait you go to john custom
right
we're not dropping into the game with
everybody in this room so we may not
is that correct no we're jumping
oh my gosh big risk
um
yeah it's a home screen what's a select
playlist or whatever that button is and
then it's on the bottom right or you
press control
the code is five seven eight
sorry
so we got 11 more spots even though i
know you were wrong there i still got
nervous
i'm here for something there's something
wrong with you
i don't even know where to put it in so
this is so much stream
the smoking dragons right at me that's
the best i love that
thank you i thought i tried to put the
code on the picture in
like three times before i realized
okay only 10 spots left we're going to
do it it's going to happen
this is okay it's going to happen my
gosh
the video game is happening that's
what's happening
we're so close we're so close waiting to
watch five rounds of chaos
i just want to wish everyone good luck
but you know i'm never going to lose
i've never lost this game ever so
i just want to remind everyone that they
can go to tiltify.com
at charlanazard to uh donate to the
tiltify campaign hey thank you queen
you absolute queen or exclamation point
thank miss yes that was also a command
of mine well i just stood up i
didn't do that i probably should have
done that i did donate but mika i saw
that you tried to go into my stream
earlier and find it
i did i could see that you had left on
chat
i was like i really hope this works or
i'm going to be embarrassed
when it didn't work and i was like yeah
i'm sorry about that i'm sorry about
that i should have set it up
could you maybe tell everybody listening
what we're raising money for
today i did do that on my stream but
hello everyone we are raising money for
thank miss which is for uh
red nose day which is specifically to
end child poverty basically
help kids get food clothes education
even
um would love to raise around twenty
thousand dollars today so donate if you
can
uh we got a whole bunch of cool creators
helping out to try and hit the goal
tonight if
possible but we'll see
hold on alana i was commuted can you say
that again um
we're trying to end child poverty you
absolute monster
there you go wow hey john go [ __ ]
yourself okay so john i have a question
that you can help with for some reason
people can only hear me from their left
speaker right now on obs
oh yeah you need to uh
[Music]
a microphone uh if you click on advanced
audio properties yeah
uh and then is it is mono checked under
your microphone no no here should i do
one left slide
yeah check that would help okay sounds
like you're out of luck we did it
[Music]
well there was never gonna be 80 people
from from the jump was the thing hey
what these people already in green team
what do you mean
wow
for keane francis oh good he's going to
be making moves
coolest thing i've ever heard okay do we
have enough people in here right now
we have 50 sticks are there four more
people still trying to get in well i
don't know if we have 56 people in
discord right now what is it it's 15
plus 16
plus 15. plus 11. can someone do that
math please
one more one more plus one more
uh alana i uh i changed all the chats
here to be out of 99 so you can see
exactly how many oh my god you're
you're an angel that's the discord pro
tip everyone take notes it's very
valuable
see alana your problem here fails
because i'm a youtuber i do not do
math all right i'm starting the show i'm
starting the show it's the same here the
show is starting
all right time for the show
though because otherwise we can only
terrorize the first yeah get the [ __ ]
out of green team you jokes get into a
chat what do people need to use green
teams
[Music]
what's going on yeah we got we got a
minute before we start
where do we go um we're like we're
starting right now i'm starting right
now
oh hi
ross can you link me to the discord
overlay or whoever set that
[ __ ] not right now i would need to win
yeah okay win first
green team
this is the most chaotic where are you
at
oh no i lost you okay oh this is
wait how do you see people's user names
how do i see them when i'm playing it's
lt
oh there it is there it is oh wait this
game is way better on controllers
yeah i'm on control oh yeah you might
want to you might want to swap over
that's gonna be a little bit
i'm proud that's right i'll try it at
one point they start terrorizing people
this is so [ __ ] chaotic the amount of
people talking
together there's so much happening in
general what i have to qualify dude i'm
streaming
if you spot the potted monkey you know
that a green team member has made it
through
we should uh change our all of our skins
to something green next round
yeah i i do not change my costume i'm
sorry
uh okay the dink will have to match you
then huh
it's too iconic to change all right wait
this is a good oh i haven't touched this
one's cool
the [ __ ] is this i haven't made it to
the end of this one get to the top
three mini games bottle opener at the
top this is really pretty oh yes
this is the one i'm really bad at okay
all right this one's pretty good
actually
i'm a big fan of this over the last
season oh i didn't see that
oh okay well this season they added the
mini games that people wanted the
obstacles
time waits for no one my friend
where do you go oh my god there's so
much going on
did not show up for me don't get that
ball out of my way
oh my gosh
oh this launches you this is really
funny to watch
this is so much
this is so funny to watch
oh and i'm about to call oh oh i see
okay okay okay okay okay uh-oh it's only
knights orange
hell oh my god dude that was i like this
that was oh oh what the [ __ ] i didn't
expect that
keen frantic baller i've got you where
is can't break
it okay okay okay i'm gonna qualify i'm
gonna qualify with qualifying i'm
watching you keen frantic baller get up
go green
all right
and there's times where i thought i got
the crown like i was like second and i
touched it and then i still got the lock
come on man just give me the crown it's
like pity crown more losers are joining
hey what's up oh here we go
uh how do i expand this dang thing so i
can see who i'm talking to
is there a way to click the channel the
voice channel name and it'll bring up
everybody's boxes
i can't help but notice that uh you also
had to leave green team because you were
eliminated that's interesting
[Laughter]
mr diehard green team has also showed up
in the eliminated lobby
yeah well you know what green team is
still the best they will carry on in my
stead
i haven't seen any of these new games
what is this yeah
i don't know where any of this is
are the only one that thinks the balls
look like gobstoppers
people have actually joined the correct
uh team discords does red team only have
three people except for green
yeah except for red team i'm gonna go
bully them excuse me i suspect that some
of your
red punks are hanging out here in the
green let's get a nice lawn nice launch
off this bonker
there is no green team you're in the
wrong voice chat
no no where
[Music]
exciting to see everybody in here i just
went into this vine
this is beautiful isn't it what happened
to the blue ball oh
look at that big ball it basically gets
big when it gets bigger
tried any of the new stuff when did did
this just come out with this season
wednesday right yeah it seems like a
winter wonderland thing it's cool oh wow
all right well it's done
pulled it off you guys doing all right
you guys doing okay in here
oh well winning is what we're doing wait
you guys won who got knocked then
yes was it yellow who got knocked out
red did let me go sass red
gets bigger hey are you guys doing okay
you all right yeah exactly i'm sorry for
your loss
oh sorry i just uh i got stuck here on
my way back to the top
i don't want to be here anymore was it
dave's fault i feel like it was probably
dave's fault
oh my gosh okay is my audio okay
everyone
i wanted to ask that okay oh hey liam
hey how are you
mate i wanted to make sure that my my
audio is okay for the people watching
the stream
it was delightful i think it sounds
wonderful beautiful
did you get eliminated what happened i
did indeed get eliminated in round two i
haven't done any of the new stuff
so i don't know any of these yeah wait
is this the final one
no okay no no there's like at least this
one this is also the worst by the way so
the you know you know
this one might be the worst yes yeah i
hate this with all my souls that i got
eliminated
well because this one you have to like
move the you have to move the stuff
around
in order to i hate anything where i have
to help someone else win
where i'm like i'll move the box no you
move the box i [ __ ] hate them
for that reason cecil drives me next
it's the worst
just be the biggest [ __ ] and you win
yeah busy first
yeah is a team game is what i'm saying
it's supposed to be that's how physics
work
feels like it's like hmm a communal game
and then half the community doesn't want
to help so i don't know if it's a
team game communal games and team games
different things
uh well yes yes because communal there
could be a leader in a community but a
team should have no leader team chevron
should be equals okay
the communal game it's you could still
as michael jordan says there's no
iron team but there is a win i think we
all know that
i know axe i'm calling big hacks you are
boss dance is so good
it's the first time it really is i
really don't have too much going on
chicago bulls or too much attachment to
it but what a good documentary
oh that's my team that's always been my
team so it knows awesome that's real
personal
yeah it matters to me as an australian
what's great to me
what's great to me i don't know if they
win some of these games or not when it's
like oh no
it's a 98 conference finals do they win
i have no idea oh really
oh it's exciting to me it's spoiler
alerts everywhere in my household
oh they they just keep winning right
that's probably what happens oh
so if we find someone hacking what do we
do to them make them pay a thousand
dollars to the charity
somebody in here is hacking but i hope
not
good luck friends good luck thank you
thank you
i've never won jump showdown
myself so they can't hear me
just silent everyone's just dead silent
who is it it's so we've got who's in
here
trying to read these names yusuf
um that's
i can't figure out who it is that's
definitely okay we've got yousef we've
got miranda
tazzy meg kaley oh wow wow wow that
dropped an interesting group
i can't believe how quiet i can't
believe it oh it's intense
everyone's so quiet pounding
no
no so close
so close
what if i just like really politely
shout cost
where you see this creamy giggling baron
right yep
uh so we've got yusuf in his in his nice
little uh snow outfit here
yeah he jumped over the gold pole that's
an interesting choice oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that didn't look good for you oh god uh
will scarlet you know being real
confident over here oh no it's not will
scarlet scarlet monster who's that who's
that who's that who's that
let's call it monster there are too many
too many no no they're not all in here i
don't know who it is
i'm on team falling hippo meg kaylee's
the wise sparkling wolf
she's muted so she's not playing
technically brie is playing
i'm trying to figure it out no i'm not
i'm not maybe our final round
contestants are not actually all in here
they could be wherever who knows
i think he is like 120 now yeah yeah
yeah he's nuts
he's the one with horns
yeah he just got obliterated he like
jumped a little bit early and then just
got slapped
oh no
[Music]
you that's it that's a twitch name oh my
god that's a really good name though
that's good who is it so they're already
here it's steve
later zaragoza zaragoza yeah
eve zara we can keep
right now
it's only like a 24-hour band don't
worry
i see a wrench in my chat and i'm like
oh god okay everybody
alana said we can keep playing same code
so just stay in this room one day
but i think we probably have more people
who want to join so i'm just trying to
see if
oh like johnny
can i buy them off you i haven't got any
i'm free
it made me think like i should make one
of those master class videos but for
fall yeah
you should yeah yeah john did you did
you get back in because i know you are
welcome to my
disconnected right
i've missed so many crowns i've like
done the jump and just falling out of my
grasp and some chump behind me just
takes it oh hey
uh i didn't even know what a crayon is
until just this oh my god
crazy
i'm not mad at it what's up how you
doing how's everybody going just gonna
wait for a couple more people
up here see what happens that's me
that's me what's up oh you guys heard of
her
you know around here
[Music]
this is going to be your quiet room when
you come here yeah
it's like i need i need not 70 people to
be talking people i do
need to continue to get mad at green
team though they need to just don't i
mean
that's just that should be given i mean
you have to at that point i mean this is
the rules i'll go in and yell at them
occasionally
um all right i think i'm good to start
the show alana i wanted to basically say
thank you for organizing this whole dang
chaos this is absolutely so much fun
it is already a lot of fun and it's i
like that i get to know which of my
friends has won
every single round like i feel like
that's so neat like that was steve
zaragoza yeah and that's like such a
cool thing to be able to like
oh that dude what steve
he's some random [ __ ] yeah all right
let's go let's go
let's start the show shelby
hello i can play for one more and then
i'm
going to bed oh yeah because it's laid
up for you isn't it
only 9 30 but i'm going to bed at 9 30.
[Music]
what's wrong with you
oh goodness it was the last day of work
before vacation it's true
that's true hello welcome to the stream
hello hello
what up i meant some you i meant to mute
i'm sorry
your partner on twitch don't know how to
mute jesus
[Laughter]
we you how big are you winning sun
energy that was big
are you winning you know what because of
that zombae i want you to win
oh my gosh oh my god what is happening
live jesus come on
[Laughter]
i don't know which part you're at no i'm
gonna tell my dad to get out of my chat
right now
i like all the fans i like those those
are fun yeah yeah
those are pretty pretty pretty dope
actually zombie knows a lot about fans
oh [ __ ] oh my god
at least seven at least seven
love the little yeah noise that you get
when walking on the ice platform
gosh this is so competitive all right
went through what through fans are
[Music]
stupid
[Music]
i hate it happened last time again
happy little moon i love the little
witch costume that's the wait it named
me sorry
it was nice talking to you guys i love
you please we'll see you soon
goodbye i'm gonna go hang out and
eliminating
okay oh that may have been you that i
saw you guys doing strats in here
uh no yes there's a group please don't
steal our strats
our strategy is succeeding in this game
all right guys my strategy here is i'm
going to walk towards the end
that's a good strategy all right good
try good good good good good good good
good good good straight good try i'm
going
[Laughter]
silly sneaking creature the the problem
with that people were hacking is that
like bald eyes is definitely watching
this stream like they just out
themselves
immediately you you have to have big
balls to cheat in here yeah
oh no oh no guys
i just spawned in top of somebody
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't think there's enough people
watching
it's just every time that i walk it tips
and i hate it
where do i go okay
if i press x will i grab is that the
situation
yeah whatever big bonkers
[Music]
i do not know how to grab is my problem
right trigger
if you guys don't jump into your actual
colors in the team rounds you're just
kind of being jerks to everyone else
all right you can go back to green team
as soon as you want
okay all right all right all right we're
green teaming
yeah you can always wrap the green
underneath the blue red or yellow
sleeper cell agents in the green team
exactly
was too advanced for me i mean because
you said brigitte
was your favorite thick bloncus never
forget
no i understand this one now so i think
i've
i think i remember to dive before
hitting the ground
yeah i'm not in a great i really don't
want to mess with the uh the
punching up oh we got here yeah i yeah
[Music]
i just killed someone oh that's awesome
did everyone oh
did everyone just freeze in the air or
did i just see that no
no i ain't moving i didn't oh well
ethan that was beautiful ethan you
nailed it back thank you so much
you have a really good job i believe in
you oh thank you
the zany pop and wizard oh that was so
bad oh [ __ ]
this okay oh no
no not great ethan's not great that
wasn't what you wanted
not the outcome very very bottom uh oh
yeah
no i need more i need more momentum
uh-oh
[Music]
the ball around so okay we know you're
still green bro
we know you're still green we will never
forget you
please remember me i'll do my best i'll
i'll yell at him real hard if they lose
i'm gonna go see what the eliminated
will be hail tag
okay all right i'm going to stand up and
go to the bathroom i'll be back
i'm going to sit here and pop off for my
green team friends
i think
you look at a lobby of 20 people and you
think it's not going to be loud
yeah i went in and i was like all right
it's not the same it's not your green
team there are 20 people i'm going to go
for it it's
gary's doing he's just running around
and it's the last second someone takes
it it doesn't matter yeah
like i feel like he's played more of
this game than almost anyone else
probably in the server i would think i
my favorite part yeah every time someone
says it it goes up by 10.
oh
oh gary what are you doing buddy
[Music]
oh
we have already raised two thousand five
hundred dollars
that's incredible that's not nearly
enough
people alana yeah this is the final
this is the final final round
thanks for putting this together of
course i don't like this pressure
steve you're so good at this i i don't
like it he is great
if you're in the final round please get
in the final round lobby jump over there
oh right
i don't know if you fall out you can
just fall off so don't
fall off or do they both roll different
ways you should
probably oh it's like there's probably
gonna be something goofy like
confetti and poop falling at us i don't
know those holes there's holes now
there's holes
i haven't seen this one before don't
fall off like the movie oh he's getting
grabby already
go call go call you got this call madam
cerrone
forever andy dirty
hold the risky move it paid off in the
end nope oh okay
oh boy howdy i'm gonna watch that oh
i'm just rested i don't trust your
people it's a good movie
i love how i'm ready for that i'm trying
to like i'm not speaking to them right
now god
i'm doing that around you absolute i
hate you
i hate you who did it who's the evil
mastermind the unicorn
oh that unicorn unicorn
oh my god their first name is angry evil
angry evil monster that's one brand two
on the nose
angry evil am i wrong and assuming steve
is still in here
so not saying that you guys should go
after steve but uh what
i cannot believe that steve's era goes
to skill it's shocking yeah stephen
saragoza is actually insane
snow bike mike oh dear hold yours see
the dude who was trolling us before evil
oh no hey dan is that you stop touching
me
yes oh this is oh yeah you guys snowbike
snowbike mike is angry i know how are
you
hi who who are you what's your name best
good kitten
best good kid i'm spiky teal chum
and i'm i will never kill you unlike
angry evil monster
evil monster is an angry evil monster so
it's no it's snow bike mike and he's
like one of the most pleasant people
i've ever
a known like he's awful yeah but he's
really mean in this game
okay so it's so it's mike and is there
only one of them
who won who won
michael
[Music]
they are unhappy with you mike you have
you have uh you have upset a lot of
people
[Music]
mike you upset a lot of people they're
really not happy with your ethics
you're talking mad
he's a [ __ ] griefer and look what
happened
bang i almost got andy he's lucky i let
go of him amazing
like i had my eyes on you the whole
[ __ ] time i was like i do not want to
mess around with this guy right now
dave over here i go andy cortez is right
next to me check out what i'm about to
do to him and i turned and grabbed him
let him know i'm here andy that's all
just fun to let you know nothing more
painful than watching a grief of winter
crown
guys i mean we watched what happened
with krampus in the last one
yep you know that was punished mike that
wasn't regular mike that was
punished for the record you guys we've
already raised two thousand five hundred
dollars
that's the best that's awesome
you want to make a new channel for the
leaderboard that you see who have won so
far
yeah i can know i can do that let's go
that would be cool
if i go a new text channel not me
distracting you from
game starting you know i don't need to
do anything people win tonight kind of
put me up on the leaderboard you stand
right next to me
dave i'm looking for you that little
blue bean let's stay together now come
on
andy was telling me you're pro win
yourself i've played a lot of fall guys
and talked a lot of fall guys so
that's what i was trying to figure out
mike was who's played the most and i
actually guessed gary might have
like in the server a lot but i don't
know
i mean there are a lot of streamers in
here but not many people who played a
ton of fall guys
um yeah i
i might be one of the top for sure gary
and i might be closed
because he has that but yeah i would say
for me playing wise yeah i've played a
lot of lana you know that i don't know
yeah alex put in does not equal being
good at the game
no i cannot believe steve zaragoza won
the first that i was like steve of all
people like i
should never have doubted him how random
he got his second round too
yeah i know he was also in the finals of
the second round it's crazy oh
[ __ ] chat i should be doing this
fight chat guys
well so i've not played any of the new
stuff so you know pretty
oop i just got eated um so pretty you
know unexpected
a lot of uh mm-hmm i like all those
that's gonna be a learning curve the fan
base
[Music]
yeah i gotta not make try to go for that
shortcut anymore you know that's an
option
yeah you gotta skip that you gotta skip
that and go on the easy one andy is
right
i am looking at a first round exit right
here mikey i'll be rude oh
get first rounded no you're about to get
first round no no you guys where's my
guy dave at dave you in
i'm not andy son of a fight i have
qualified
easy questions you got this gary this is
clean
nobody else even around that's nice
okay gary you don't get to yell easy
qual where okay when you're 38.
it's not quite what happens
i think gary was like asleep for the
first 30 seconds of that so
it was pretty i was getting knocked
around by the big fan and having a rough
time to recover
i'll take it and then somehow steve
zaragoza is out here winning
can we talk about everyone you can't
adjust your audio uh in the middle of
the rounds
so oh this game is so loud huh
yeah it's just so loud
it's intense i messed up in a good way
my game is coming off the speaker
so if i'm wearing headphones that's a
smart call
all right let's keep going let's keep
going oh yeah here we go freezy peak
y'all in this everybody
how are you doing miles i don't feel
like i've been smoking you in a while
how's stuff i know
uh stuff's good uh i'm playing oh my god
um these
[Music]
dungeon dragon fans lately oh cool
jesus very nice very nice
please stop grabbing me i'm just a boy
oh gosh oh no the fan got me
yeah just getting like once to my beans
okay i think i'm oh [ __ ] okay here we go
now we're up
this the god damn snowballs i've never
seen snowballs
it's either go to the right and get
fisted or go to the left and get balls
to the face
sounds like my ideal friday night
can i go down the middle yeah you can
have both if you want dave i'm not gonna
shave you i love that these fists knock
you into the things that
eat you up under the air that's such
evil design
oh my god this is designed by the same
guy that designed slime
is it actually because it i believe you
yeah we
we actually uh we played with the
designer of this today and he was
talking us through the design of it it's
really it was fun
here we go
oh no damn it i just screwed up the
landing on that lost fan
you hate to see it you hate to see it i
hate to see that
like that see it has passed hey guys
what's up keen frantic baller there
this time i'm around there stage and i
wish it was never born green guy damn
i don't you know what aaron i agree like
i'm
[ __ ] i don't know what he said but i
like stupid disagree
or whatever i like guys it's okay
i'm still in it
not that many team games huh did they
scale them down we've only had one
yeah that was a while ago that was like
the first patch it's way harder to get
team games
really huh this is my favorite one it
sucks
team games are so fun especially when
you have lobbies like this
exactly this is the first time we can
actually all talk to each other and they
don't do that
give us the damn team games all over
eight points nimble evil spirits i'm a
big fan
i am the potted monkey so if you see the
potted monkey run
i'm gonna get this guy out for last time
he griefed me on jump jumping
yes yes i got him oh my god
wow that was so fast wow easy
i'm just glad that i killed that get one
guy are we going
one more thing finale
oh my god i haven't played fall ball in
so long i want to play it so it's been a
minute
have you seen a big house hexagon like
finale is pretty cool
but what did they change this one right
here this one oh
no i haven't seen it what's it like it's
like hexagon but
different yeah it's ice it's icy
yeah oh jeez yo what up goodbye
okay let's go let's win some crowns i've
never won a crown before what is this
level i've never seen oh liam you are
you in here your little muffin
let me see hexagon yeah that's my
muscletown it's crunchy hexagon
this looks awful little muffin is that
you cole
it's something watch out for the unicorn
he's evil
unicorn is minion
okay let's go let's go oh this is
interesting
okay strong game strong game strong
early game
i don't understand oh oh it's just like
little different kinds of legends
cole who are you i'm uh oh i don't know
my what's my name
cloudy jeweled samurai my ogre pickle
burger okay
i see you i see you i see you you really
are an older pickle burger
that's really good that's what i try to
be every day try to live my life being
another pickle bugger you know how it is
wake up in the morning look in the
mirror you know grouping over
what even is the strat for this then
like you just like i think stand on them
until they break and then there isn't
much of a strat
until the end until the ends so kind of
the same as normal hexagon
yeah but different because it's season
three
i lost a hexagon in the most epically
sadly the closest i've ever been to a
crown
i was in hexagon and i was like getting
oh god
um i just want to tell my chat by the
way the australian man who is currently
talking if you did not know
is uh jd phoenix in gears of war um
you would not know based on that oh [ __ ]
liam i put you on the spot i'm so sorry
oh i'm so angry when everybody was
paying attention
everyone was paying attention to you 100
okay are you still here
oh i choked
[Laughter]
oh this is so epic all these people
angry snow bike mike is eating you're
gonna win
no not the snow bike
he's going to win again oh it's wrong oh
my god
can we kick him
can we kick him mike are you [ __ ] me
[Music]
by the camera on that last round there
are you sure you didn't get [ __ ] by
snowbike mike
because no i i i stay the [ __ ] away from
mike because that's
the number one tip i'll give you just if
you see him just [ __ ] turn around and
go the other direction going for the
three feet mike just like jordan
yeah gary i want you to know the entire
eliminated chat was rooting for you
alana i leaked it like an idiot okay for
some reason
we'll start i'll start a new code big
[ __ ] dummy chills
after getting disconnected it kept the
code there it was like uh oh
that's okay i'll start anyone after this
i'm so pissed because i was doing so
well
yeah i was on the outer edge and then
the camera the way i rotated the camera
it brought a wall up in front of me and
obscured my view for a second and then
that doesn't suck
but also it's not like i said i was
coming after you
yeah that's the key at least i didn't
end up in a one-on-one with mike
because i would i would i would have
lost that battle of wills
who's the most person that keeps
he's dressed like a unicorn just kill
the unicorn one of you sacrifice
yourself
i'll do it right now i'm looking right
now
he's angry something unicorn angry angry
evil monsters that's it that's it sorry
yeah there it is okay but he's dressed
as a unicorn yeah
he's correct a little misdirect little
misdirect
he's out there in front already on the
left-hand side
i think this is oh i'm getting bonkers
oh gosh how are you people oh every time
you're doing this at the same time nope
nope
it all comes so hinky i tried your strat
on the fan in the middle and it failed
no it's a terrible plan never do it
always go left always go left yeah
always go left oh i just got smacked oh
dude
all right let's go all right i did not
get eaten
here we go here we go oh my god we got
griefers
that's unfair
[Laughter]
there's a couple plant monkeys that i
may have picked one
i don't know you play a whole bunch you
run a tournament around fall guys and
then that's how you learn
yeah i mean he's he's costed the game
he's you know he's got his time in but
hey maybe steve zaragoza can beat him
maybe no
uh just i'm focused it doesn't matter
the quality 5 000 now this is amazing
yeah like one with my ski ball
yeah that's okay points yes this points
you gotta get fifteen
one yeah i normally don't care about
numbers but let's get them
it's points how does that work it's
point based you'll see
like up at the top oh boy up at the top
oh god that was so bad i'm so
bad at this one no me too i just want to
say
speed
oh
there you go okay okay the thing can
stop the things
is
he got it
[Music]
i hope you guys in my stream are
clicking on that link there yeah
5k that's always 6k clicking is
trying to get rid of child poverty it's
a pretty good cause i recommend it
hell yeah i like it i want everything
in this nation to have at least five
million dollars in the bank account
evil spirit where is he oh he's already
got the gold egg
oh you'd love to see it he loves all
guys
okay i have an update to the clark
situation
you can now just look at someone's tweet
of carp
and then you can press a button and it
automatically tweets
yeah i'm sorry what are you talking
about i feel like i missed a lot of
context
if you check twitter you will understand
okay i'm checking twitter
just tell us what the first thing that
you see
if you see my magikarp tweet i'm sorry
oh i'm i'm seeing a tweet from blessing
right now about deus ex mankind divided
so
um that's not what i was talking about
no i don't think so
no it's unrelated i'm pretty sure yeah
maybe you gotta scroll a little bit i
don't know
i would never don't don't look at the
hashtag part that's now not safe to work
with
oh god come on cade do it for the green
team
i think this is looking like a yellow
team victory right it is looking like a
yellow team victory if ever i've seen
one
that's that coordination
it's nice when you have four people on a
team but when you have the entire team
coordinating they're unstoppable i do
want to see what they're talking about
let me just jump over here
oh yeah another one another one another
oh yeah he's looking real bad
oh thank you raiders who rated me thank
you whoever rated it on twitch i
appreciate that i can't tell who did it
we have broken uh carson rated me oh
that's cool
no yellow team it's the old team goal
team rules
you just need a rebranding need to
rebrand for sure
i appreciate that this is the money
we've raised for red nose day it's
because of this
there we go it's great yellow team well
done
yellow team killed it also we hit 6000
much for the holiday cheering the love
what are you doing here by yourselves
good job goldberg you probably just do
it in here by yourselves i don't trust
it
i don't trust it for a second we're
yelling we're shouting we're having fun
over here
right alana you're still in no i got i
got knocked out years ago yeah it wasn't
a good time
okay i think you're still in right you
know yeah
it was this one that knocked me out it
was the final fan i have trouble like
landing on the outside rim
at the very top so that's okay that's
where i got knocked
um because i just didn't land on it
right and then and then i was done full
it's done
then you slide right up yep exactly done
for so it's all about yeah just that
camera angle as you know and just slide
try to belly flop onto the big one okay
lana let's talk about it happy holidays
how have you been everything going well
i'm doing good yeah i'm actually going
away um which is going to be really nice
to me as someone who has spent you know
most of this year in a very very small
apartment
yeah um i got a cabin in the woods it's
sort of in the middle of
sort of oh nice so i'm very excited
about murdered
that's awesome well you know what do i
gotta live for this year really
yeah i mean we're gonna download it it
might as well be this year not a big
deal
no i'm very excited to just be outdoors
and have space
um so i'm gonna do that next week can't
wait how are you guys doing
wonderful we finished our final kind of
funny x-cast episode
so i did too i mean it's not like people
are thinking wrong
it's what he wrote in the tweet no he i
was like wait i think
i thought we were still doing wait we
got cancelled this is how i find out
yeah
a lot of he came into the slacktail and
goes so we don't why anymore and i said
what are you talking about
that's when i thought i was out i'm out
oh that's the thing apparently yeah that
was a freezing quality
oh no we're gonna root you on what are
we looking at here
hey mike i'm gonna ask you that if you
if you keep qualifying though uh
make sure you jump into that that uh
final round lobby
because i think that's me if this is the
final lobby let me uh that's the content
i really want to see i want to watch
those people competing with each other
in these final rounds they're going to
be really fun but i don't know if this
is going to be yeah
it's the final round final round it is
yeah it's just around the chat around
where is it it's under general three
little uh little trophy oh god
bam around hello
i never win this one though for real
though i have like 220 crowns and i
think jesus
no no but i literally think like three
of them are on this one like i
always lose matt they have to oh i
called you matt that's so weird for me
they have to adjust to like all guys
there are people have like thousands
yeah yeah the inflation's a bit insane
right now
i'm uh i'm watching crazy frantic
streamer right now
that's me nice to meet you smart spam
whatever oh god the pressure the
pressure
what you're like a robo kitty outfit
that's the queen [ __ ] with this little
girl
the platforms
drops that'll be interesting that will
be
these two on the end here and steve
zaragoza
yeah me either everyone was very
surprised all right i'm very
eliminated i guess uh people
in someone's stream i forgot who are
donating to the cause under
uh gen 2 because we're all like a family
there
lol very nice very nice
what am i trying to do here we go no oh
raise money
for red nose day hell yeah that's right
i'm i'm going for you
damian i would like you to oh well okay
well
well you know what uh what were we
well it's because i want variety in our
winners and right now it's snow bike mic
so like mike snowbike mike
right i'm not snow bike mike
that is true
cloudy jeweled summer i think it's cold
no i'm uh i'm klutzy daring sidekick
also i'm banning anyone in your chat
who's not cheering for me
i killed the grabber i killed the
grabber come on scarlet
[Music]
that camera angle did not make me
comfortable
grab me how many we okay we still got it
i want their name
oh you got it who is it then and it was
a
sweep oh my god
the hamburger man on how you kill people
damn what a basic dude
yeah i think is that not i think that's
steve again isn't it oh it's steve again
i think it is i think he's
that damn it who's hamburger man though
uh
hamburger man is coal um i believe is
called
correctly why did steve go where is he
you [ __ ] chuck
yeah wrong steve that was you again
right the game's broken right that was
me again
you're a pro dude steve tonight
[Laughter]
um they're so cute and really fun
they're either adorably sleeping or
they're running and jumping on literally
everything
oh god heaven uh yeah just so you guys
know
somebody leaked the code so i'm getting
a new code oh
who was the person it was chilled it was
chilled
wow what what chad is he is is he in gen
2 still
he might be i'm not sure all right let
me grab a new one
oh let me hide it from the internet
first
unlike chill [ __ ]
joe had zero joe
[Laughter]
i like i like how it's in all caps too
gold was league
[Laughter]
it was chilled your boy chills chaos
chaos
no he showed it before that game but
because it's the same code it just means
that people could join in at any point
right right
there we go this code is very
satisfying for some reason it is a
little bit it works
but i also have mad beef with the fact
that they have
both zeros and o's in their codes
can we just pick one that doesn't count
as a leak it doesn't count as a leak
people are gonna just happen every
variation
[Laughter]
i'm not certain on that last character
so i'm gonna make a guess
yeah no you'll be fine you'll be you'll
be fine it's it's the one you think it
is
all i'm saying so what do you think it's
only got two options so
well
[Music]
[Laughter]
we get your best fall guys impression
everyone in three two one
i don't know what you're asking for oh
the way they sound
um
is
uh are you guys all in we won't work
see the problem with saying if they're
level 100 then the lions would win
because then okay if we're bringing
level logic into this then why not bring
pp logic
the pokemon literally does not have
enough attack they get tired after
beating my ass for five minutes probably
ran out of pp the pokemons really do not
have enough pp to no it's not who would
you fight it's who would win
the lions they're fighting one another
yeah and a billion lines are fighting
all of the pokemon who win
okay okay now it makes sense level
like they only can learn certain moves
based on level though that's the thing
well we can say they have access to
their full poll
but to say like but actually i'll try
explosion hits all targets therefore one
million lions
no because ghost types are immune so the
pokemon would survive
but those guys are already dead buddy
yeah so they can't die again i think
can you imagine if you named your entire
online presence after a pokemon that
dude that's a weird name for a pokemon
ultra i've never heard of that one
before
no it's this uh this elana this
charlotte
situation
yeah that's the part that makes me the
most uncomfortable yeah
oh my god everyone can we tip the scales
i can't believe my friends would do this
to me
it's less annoying when it's people you
don't know
i'll continue my point oliver age 24 if
you are watching i've been watching you
for seven years
please dm me okay you've been saying
this for a while and i'm still
not sure entirely what it means somebody
in this server has to have the
connections
to all of your agents 24 is the
community manager of fall guys oh my god
i have been watching his youtube content
oh nice laughs
i've been watching his youtube comments
my
you're not technically wrong about that
i'm not gonna argue with it okay we're
about to
find out how many gamers we have in this
lobby it's not me
so that's all i can do i got a limited
that's [ __ ] me
i got it limited i've done slime climb
guys
not just the one he wins the whole
[ __ ] thing right
here he's down to that ground yeah
listen i'm not trying to do it i don't
want to get sick
oh
oh
[Music]
be safe there's no time limits
not a gen 2 move i'll tell you that
myself
let's go baby
discord in the office right now they're
checking the stats and they're
well i'm going to be eliminated so i'll
see you later
like in a private game if they should
yeah that's that's a good point i could
actually tell them that directly modern
that if it's a private game that we
could just have our own names that's a
good call
i just don't know how the public is
going to do it when you have to have a
minimum of 40 people
yeah my friends
are going to be streamers and frat
houses
we hit 7k that's amazing
guys take your time and be patient thank
you steve
i i love you even though you know you
you too good too good at video game
and you all right we're also on the same
panel right now we're basically holding
hands steve
i'm really not that good at video games
well okay
oh my god it's like i'm not even that
good now stop
like like i'm not oh my gosh
is that an american i hear yeah like
it's not a big deal
like i know i have one twice but i'm oh
it's not even that good yeah but yeah
but this is scary now
this is so many people for the [ __ ]
chaos of what this is i know i don't
like it
i love it i've i've been disconnected
from the game
oh good we'll take that we'll take that
we'll take that disconnect that's that's
uh
nope i just jumped off i didn't even i
didn't do anything i just jumped
jump in here i feel like it's him you're
still going what's up pumpkins krampus
is still going
let's go eggman you can do it eggman
come on eggman
oh my god this
oh [ __ ] who is an unbelievable spirit
yeah let me figure that out who is
nimble evil spirits
that was amazing
my gosh you've done it i did it
you did it yeah i did your work for you
too
[Laughter]
and reply to it he's correct
you've done it you've taken out steve
zaragoza and snowbike mike
i'm so happy about that
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm just going
to delete that message boom
is the collective we've said this okay
one win for green team
yes
all right uh you want me to move the
donation panel thing so that
we can see the thing on the right what's
on the right uh but yeah i can move it
hang on hang on
let me move it over here shall i does
that help
with other names up there maybe also
seven thousand dollars my gosh thank you
guys so much keep donating we're trying
to raise money to erase um
child poverty it's a pretty good cause
pretty good cause we're all for it
so here we go okay
hey everyone we've raised seven thousand
dollars
there are so many of us in this one
general chat jesus christ it's because
it's the whole
time nobody
is in general three can i tell you this
is one guy
go ahead seems to have just organically
emerged as like the cool channel to be
in the outlets
because we don't grab we don't leak
not anymore he's changed
the person who leaked the code was one
of the people who screams the most mario
hopping on my face
hey joey noel did i did i text you about
stacks closing down
no yeah i know
is that not like the saddest thing
you've ever done yeah we got a lot of
pancakes at stacks
back in the day people painting pancakes
i get it
exactly you know they're really sick the
only olive garden in san francisco just
closed down
do you think that on the menu on the
last day they said
endless soup and breadsticks it has now
ended
oh no yeah limited soups listen
was it there a
it's going for it it honestly wouldn't
really matter if we accidentally leak it
and like fill the wall of columbia but
i'd prefer not to
you know not totally understandable it's
crazy is it understandable to you of all
people but
children
it you got to do it
all right let's go red team in this team
okay all right
i'm stuck uh i don't know i'm going to
protect you i protect you i'm here
thanks elaine
mike's coming back liam
yeah okay okay we're good that's good
hustle good hustle team that's it
right who's clutzy daring sidekick all
right
oh that's me that's me just give it to
me they're really
oh [ __ ] i'm so sorry that that's just
happening that's okay
a huge bummer okay here we go oh okay
[ __ ] off
got a tail got
that's a thing that most people have not
said but i'm
i'm happy you feel that way about
loneliness yeah i'm glad it's working
out for you
corona is good for me right now you're
back in australia please please
please stay yeah one and a half meters
away from me guys thank you very much
but it seems like it's amazing get the
[ __ ] away from me steve zaragoza
get away from me
he stole it from me [ __ ] off steve i got
it back i got it back i got it back 20
seconds
okay okay
yeah it's so long oh you just boosted
somehow i think i'm yeah that's mine i
think i'm going to be right back
i think i'm all right i think we're good
i think we're good yeah we're good yeah
we're fine actually we're winning
so it's okay there's
oh
[ __ ] stealing my tails dude give me
my [ __ ] back
holy [ __ ] four seconds no i'm not
i'm not gonna get a tail we're okay
we're okay we're one
at least maybe demeters no that's not
right that's not right
um yeah i'll take diagnosis he'd have a
good time yeah let's go
all right we'll see team red as long as
one of us wins i'll feel happy hey yeah
team red is forever see you out there
all team forever yeah
sometimes you have to sacrifice for the
greener goodies
it was so good it was just like
every color chat and i went in and i
harassed all of them so that would do
worse
i think that's not true he didn't i was
in red team and he didn't do that once
that's a [ __ ] lie oh you're lying
yeah i did not true
i was more nice to red team because you
were in there but
we didn't know how clutch that was that
was the clutches green team victory
oh hi jacob here jacob yo
happy birthday is it my birthday i mean
it's somewhere maybe somewhere it is
when are you gonna officially celebrate
your birthday what time zone is like the
official probably
probably the one you're in
because my family's in australia so they
all call me on my australian birthday
and then it's a day later
yeah we just own it all the days really
jacob i won
i'm sorry one great
in one hit yeah all right guys if you
don't mind i'm gonna install
fall guys real quick okay that would
help me that would be helpful
i i somehow had it uninstalled i don't
even know how
just these things happen you know so
dash and joe
built built my computer and i
[ __ ] hate it because i they said oh
it should be good to go and i log on and
it says username
ds insert password
oh
[Music]
yo what up oh this is a good squad all
right all right but my controller's not
working so hang on
every time okay we got it what do we do
you just god damn push that ball man you
just gotta push that ball
i feel like the way that people lose
this gary you can probably speak to this
better than i can is when when people
start running ahead
and not pushing the ball
hey easy breezy covergirl
[ __ ] whoever that is we got this
all right well that's uh our work's done
so good job good job team good job
you'd love to see it
nice
mean getting to the second last round
which is upsetting me
oh yeah is this happening is this
happening get it done
let's go oh let's go oh i'm gonna lose
time i've only ever won this twice ever
i hate this with every fiber of my being
so i have
this i have a lot of crowns and i only
have two hexagons i do not have a single
crown did you guys know that about me
i don't either yeah but here we are
we're in it we're making it happen it's
okay
take this crown queen oh oh really
mine just doesn't jump at all sometimes
your bean gets tired you gotta drink
more gatorade
you know what i mean it's like nba okay
you gotta go to the gatorade spot and go
find
i had my screen focused on my other
screen so i was just falling through
because it wasn't on the right side
oh yeah i hate to see it
nope not that it's not what i want part
of it it's all good
i just don't know what the best strat is
like is it to like play it slow
slow it down after a little bit you
gotta go fast and then slow it down real
quick
that's what i feel like i'm on now but
i'm also yeah when you watch those plays
i'll stop running around and they'll
start very carefully jumping from tile
to tile okay that's what i'm doing
that's what we need
somebody especially maximize your time
on each tile is the key
just waiting everyone else wasn't it
that did not maximize the time on that
tile
it seems like there's so many of us no
no is that a
astroneer skin or does it just look like
that it just looks like astronaut
yeah it's not huge i love it thank you
but i gave myself a little pants so that
i looked like it i see that
on this time off yeah
oh [ __ ] you're right that's not good oh
no
is that you why are you laughing like
your evil con
bottom layer for me [ __ ] [ __ ] off dude
oh oh my god
are we doing this get away from the
other oh my god
how long can we get this up here
just go inside
man looking good he's got a three spot
right here horseman looking at about
four it's the hole got it
gonna be the egg damn
nimble evil spirit look at those sassy
snacks sassy snacks didn't nimble evil
spirit win last time we already wanna
yeah
yeah god damn it lewis nice at least
thank you i appreciate that that means a
lot to me um thank you for noticing
uh it's still it's fine the good news is
i don't care
so yeah i don't care either no i don't
give a [ __ ]
do you know what your fall guy's name is
he's about to find out
why he's about to find out i'll wait for
you to join before we uh
hey how do i change my name or is it
just like that you go into the settings
yeah you can you can go into
yes
[Music]
i was trying to think what outfit should
i
everyone just in case you didn't know i
hope you're having a fun time this is a
super fun for me i don't know how fun it
is to watch because it's okay other kid
you don't know these people but i'm
having a great time
uh we have raised seven thousand two
hundred dollars
a red nose day ending child poverty if
you guys want to help out let me drop
a [ __ ] link in here so you guys can
boom also donate it would be absolutely
wonderful
if you would contribute to that we'd
love to see it so um
help out raise money and child poverty
that'd be sweet
mine doesn't yeah uh i didn't have
enough characters to put captain kids so
yeah yeah i had to go alana instead of
charlana's
it was tough for a lot of us slimy
secrets
i'm really sorry
is that you jacob i don't know i'm
trying to
get you you better make sure because
once you re-roll you're not getting it
back
oh wait is it what yeah you just
randomized the names every time
yeah you just hit a button and then you
just pick something up oh i don't i
don't think i want slimy secret bonkers
somebody out there that you'll leave it
for somebody why is it asking me to link
my amazon account
that's what i thought switch prime
you can hit the tweet cart button it'll
just default
hey connor you made it a lot like when
you when you skip a pax panel in order
to just hang out with your friends
yes yes i mean um yeah i didn't do that
before
are you are you coming to make sure
we're not lost no no no i'm where i'm
actually waiting for one more person to
uh alpha's trying to get his his code in
so he can start but i mostly just saw
that connor was on the server so i
wanted to say hi the rest of you
i made it oh oh the disrespect
i'm the most important person on the
stream yeah you know i love
the amount of people who are like oh the
code expire could have got a new one i
was like
you know how discord works what are you
doing
i was i was talking to patrick i was
like yeah i want to ask if i want to be
in this and i haven't heard anything
since so who knows what's going on
and it turns out that i'm didn't read
you we've been over this
no i re i do read my messages just not
closely
for me the only person that could be
able to make that wow
so i'm
i'm going to get a drink but when i come
back if there's 47 i'll i'll start today
go to this there's also another person
in general asking to join
oh is that yeah
you should see where it says custom game
yeah alpha
the basically the code if you're on
keyboard
one code has been leaked and i would
like to say that it was not by it was
children
it was chill chaos i'm just telling
everyone that he did it um he gets no
defense it was chilled
it says please double check the code
ensure you're on the same platform as
the host
um
yeah okay got it got it guys i did the
same i think you got in and then we just
are you in or is that iffy who just
joined i'm in i'm in okay i think we're
waiting perfect
i'm ready to see the denim dino back in
action oh yeah
i'm excited out of retirement yes
the boys like the denim dino has such a
legacy
they really don't if only
all guys hadn't just completely face
planted
well you're not part of it that's why
you don't know what we're talking about
yeah that's true anyway
i guess i'll see you later green team
you're dead to me bye
guys the case is
[Music]
well yeah maybe this was a mistake maybe
we should change the name
and nothing else didn't even last long
anyway
being the protein-packed vegetable
[Laughter]
casey neistat loves those i like how you
guys are in the eliminated lobby even
though the show hasn't started you've
just already decided
[Laughter]
waiting for iffy to join i'm actually
going to propose that to gen 2. i'm
going to propose our pyramid scheme to
gen 2 right now
okay do you want 10 equity in gen 3
what 10 percent equity yeah
yeah uh i think it would i think it
would work out well i think you could
really expand your portfolio is that
coming out of my equity though
that's coming right out of the aircraft
okay so it doesn't seem like it's that
popping well i have to i want to allow
me to offer you a time
share in gen 3. no i know what you're
thinking uh
but if you book now and get two weeks
i'll throw in a third week free
and a round of golf clubs no you did not
you could probably sell me anything if
i'm being completely honest
well you know what thank you thank you a
round of golf clubs
or a round of golf because i'm not sure
the round of golf clubs
they're very smooth i think i got it i
think i got a cylinder you got to stop
the show
stop there's no equity there's equity
guys that guys that went really well
there's a lot of people coming from gen
two now absolutely
great great they love that for us yeah
they're just yeah
yeah i mean i still have 25 equity here
this is very nice i know i did
we invested early i might have told them
that you had 50. that's that's
we'll figure that out i thought you said
50.
great thanks for coming over yeah yeah
it's um we're giving away equity shares
in the business of gen 3. um
so yeah thanks for coming on we'll work
the paperwork out after this
it's so hard to compete with that gen 2
jesus it's like a conglomerate up there
but can we talk about the how the
eliminated lobby has six people even
though we haven't started
i was in that and there was a lot of
people that have got quite negative
about the game and like i'm just gonna
stay in here i don't deserve to be in a
regular general chat
no we could take the magenta and make
them work for us i feel like i should
also just reference to everyone who's
watching my stream that none of this
makes sense to you basically it's the
way that this discord server is
organized but you guys can't see
any of it on stream so it doesn't make
any sense
they all know how discord works and they
know about equity they're smart
yeah these guys have traded as we know
that hey they know a good time share
deal when it hits them in the face
no hands you're really quiet to me um i
don't know if that's on my end
yeah you're super quiet compared to
everyone else well the rest of us are
very loud yeah it could be that liam's
pretty loud
i am pretty loud that aussie bloke is
louder than that kiwi bloke
i can probably i can don't worry about
it is this all in australians
did i join the wrong equity group so
liam is australian yeah
that is anything i can present what do i
do with australian equity i don't know
how to handle that
oh yes it's only 70 u.s equity
right you might as well give me monopoly
money i'll have you know that the
australian dollar is very strong right
now
is it really it's doing well super quiet
to me um
i'll just turn you up on mine myself is
it called the australian dollar it is we
ripped it out from you guys it was great
hey
but in australia do you call it the
australian dollar or yeah yeah
well i mean we just call it dollar but
it is an aud it's a it's an
australian dollar you guys don't call
boy yes that was the perfect time to
talk about roth iras
[Laughter]
all right i was tired my boy no hands
can you speak for me see how food worked
hello
they've started calling me liam muffin
tire in the chat now and i'm not sure
how i feel about it
i think it's an improvement quite
honestly is it great good to know i'm
going to change my legal name that way
fantastic but like liam aren't you
ripped like you could not be
and i would just you just have ripped
energy because of the spot of this thing
so i just assumed you're jacked
yeah you assumed wrong that's the lie we
spell in hollywood
because i love hollywood if there's any
um agents or pro
or you know creative contacts out in in
this particular there's i'm definitely
jacked and ripped all of those things
are true
jack and rick so much yeah both those
things were once it's hard to do
to get both at once i've never been
jacked or red
you know what it's a lot of work frankly
yeah i don't think you can
can you be jacked and rip you can
because you just have to be muscular but
really lean at the same time so like
shredding
it's very difficult right stupid legally
legally that's true
come on are you jack ripped no hands
oh so it feels weird to call you no
hands i'm just trying to stick to your
username but calling you that feels like
like the wrong thing to do
his whole brand like i don't want to
sell you sure you know and he does have
no hands
it is true well there it is
all right all right all right all right
all right all right accurate then it's
appropriate yeah
it's a good username i am not a
charizard so you you're one better than
me
it's true yeah at least there's honesty
what yeah i know i know i'm
[Music]
[Music]
thank you i do do a good tweet every now
and then are you at least ill-tempered
sure no actually i feel like i'm
extremely even-tempered
yeah like it's like so boring i'm
so chill it's not not even fun it's uh
no opposite of charizard maybe wow
okay that's how we do it there we go
we're looking good
[Music]
i have trouble with the top bit of this
so all right nope
one of my favorite easy call what no i
got eliminated
[Music]
where is cole
oh this is going to be so mean
i am having a really tough time
remembering people's names in the game
that like it's it's
difficult all right no idea but it's the
only way to locate
it's apparently i'm uh popular do you
want to go in there
popular
my timeline just god bless because the
first thing that popped up was yusuf's
picture
and yes is it just a picture of yusuf
because use of some babe
nobody nobody tell you if i said that
two of them
lana we're all going to
[Laughter]
also i streamed it to several thousand
people like the top 25 weirdest things
anybody's ever said that's true it's
true guarantee truly true
yeah i'm trying to i'm sorry
[Music]
it's happening some i don't know in the
game
there was just a button that went around
that said tweet carp
and if you clicked it your account would
tweet carp and so
we all did it it's unrelated to this
stream
oh god uh well i don't know i think it's
kind of related to everything it's just
like
life right
now we all know and it's beautiful it's
dying
is like the best at social media yeah
like oh my god like he's got like a leo
meme with a co with a carp on his head
he's really good also we've raised seven
thousand five hundred dollars just now
everyone
good [ __ ] oh yeah that is what is up
amazing to who
[Laughter]
are you aware that we can all see you
did you do that
oh okay i like it you're the only one
wait what it's called
i saw khalif with his camera and i was
like oh yeah i thought i
hit something we didn't even realize
people had their cameras on you know
no no we we started we started in gen 2
and then we and then we decided to roll
it over
uh did you go in camera
oh yeah i lost already okay i just
wanted to make sure you actually got it
yeah that was intense you guys that was
it
i got eliminated at 0.5 seconds nice
nice upsetting
because i'm so clumsy i need to get the
bottle off
hey liana what are you drinking um we
just focused on the
uh our whole chat just focused on the
one person to eliminate them and we
pretty much all died and they got
through it's really
was it was it snow bike mike
a friend who has streaming expertise
jump into like chat too with me because
my nightbot is too aggressive and i
don't know how to fix it
oh he's learning that's your problem oh
no
it's getting better is it asking for
love because that yeah
i think it's just like getting really
mad about i'm unclipping
the default settings have you seen it
yeah they're super aggressive yeah i
don't know how to you can try touching
it
did not make it through tiptoe oh brutal
have you tried turning it on again let
me see if i can just
that's not a bad idea i mean i actually
like i mean i could
i could turn nightbot off it back on
again i'm trying to already get my
camera
here or not how do you guys get your
camera to turn on in here and and your
stream thing you won't do that
oh everybody looks so cute god dang it
yo what up we got some final round
players in here
no i gotta i gotta let go the actual
final round so hinky that's your amazing
wants it correct okay that is correct
you know i died already
no that about i want cole to win
where is he um um he's
he's cloudy jewel can you drag people in
here
just drag them in here yeah i could do
that let me just
welcome cloudy jeweled samurai you're in
the correct lobby now
let me grab nimble evil spirits i'm just
pulling people into the right chats
that's okay too many chats who's who's
the follower
no no his name is drive-by and i'm just
like trying to figure it out oh
okay slick boss dino
where are you i need this guy to go get
murked
slick boss diner it's there are too many
people in the discord for me to actually
drag
like it's two yeah the list
low they're too low maybe if i move them
no okay who won i wasn't paying any
attention hamburger one yeah
you won i really wanted you to win
i'm sorry i didn't meet the grass no i
wanted you to win that dope congrats
thank you
congrats congrats congrats now we can
add that too no [ __ ] get out of here
delete that you can delete that
and then we go six is cool galleon
that is what is up hey what's up
hey hey did you get help with nightbot i
did not get help with nightbot i would
love your help with nightbot okay
uh i just wanted to chill out um the
nightbots website on the left side
there is a tab called spam protection
and
by default it is like super aggro and so
if you just
disable all that it should stop oh it's
the caps and the symbols that people
aren't like yeah
god because i thought it also gives you
a reason as well so and a majority of
the ones i've seen have been
uh emotes and caps okay um so that
should show up 95
beautiful done thank you i appreciate it
all right no problem hey thanks for
putting this together this has been
super fun
oh yeah of course thanks for joining me
let's get down of course thank you thank
you
all right yeah yeah
you have the ketogenic don't knock it
until you tried it butter coffee is
amazing but
it sounds amazing also we've raised 7
580
everyone
i would also like some more that would
be very cool child poverty bad
turns out i think we universally agree
so let's get rid of it i think that's
the one thing we can always do
not great i'm sure someone disagrees
also i love that you guys have your
webcams on i find it very cute
you know wacky like
it don't matter i'm in it hell yeah if
we could use a guy like
jen too oh yeah look i'm getting
sweating right in with gentoo you do
although are you a grabber do you grab i
i mean i typically don't grab but if i
have to make it perfect
m2 hates grabbing yeah respect
boundaries man
someone in my chat said is that iffy
from auntie donna's
big ole heart of fun now on netflix
from the world's longest name for a
sketchup
world all right let's win all right here
we go
raise your hand if you forgot the game
was starting
because i have to tap out a lot for
discord oh my god the balls aren't
moving so you hear at once are you
supposed to even i actually love what
they did with the music for season three
with the church bells and stuff
big chimes in the background i like what
they did with the like renaissance
season two music too oh yeah dude yeah
the updates have been great sound design
two is really good i think this one's
better this is
[Music]
it hurts so much more when it's people
i was i was like coming third for some
of that
but i made it yeah look at you pro gamer
absolutely
chat just so you know i'm going to brb
because i thought that maybe i would
drink some wine clothes i have a couple
of white clothes maybe i'm going to get
some white clothes but i hope everyone's
enjoying the stream again
i know this is a very strange stream
because it's mostly people who know each
other talking to each other
and you know but this is crazy and such
a cool thing that they let us have
access to it's so so so neat
oh the nightbot link is wrong oh no
that's terrible let me fix that
um so it's very fun for all of us i have
no idea what this is like as a viewing
experience because i don't know that
many streamers have ever done this
you know what i'm saying i don't know
that many people have ever
um done
this it doesn't oh it does have an extra
h in it that's so stupid of me here we
go fix the nightbot link
um yeah i don't know how many streamers
have ever done streams with this many
people in it so
you know but we're having a good time
so hopefully you guys are enjoying it
there is a setting in game to keep
sounding when typing out
uh i fixed it if you guys do the donate
link at all it should work right
it should work but yeah uh because i
realize you guys also can't see when i
like jump between
lobbies which is a little bit weird um
but it's great fun for me because i know
all of these people which is the best
you know what happens um
oh they're doing a little follow thread
that's cute
very cute okay yeah i'm so sorry
nightbot didn't work that's so stupid of
me because obviously the donation is a
very important part of this yeah we're
raising money
for thank mist putting an end to child
poverty
um so flamio there is a discord overlay
but the thing is it would be effectively
useless
because uh there are so many people
talking all the time like it wouldn't
really even mean anything to you
um i could throw it in there but i also
have to put it over the other
overlay which is for the charity overlay
i just feel like for this setting it's
just like a bit
weird um
but if if you would if that would be
helpful i could do that
you can make that happen i just need
someone to to give it to me but i just
feel like it would be a [ __ ]
mess all right i'm going to be bob so i
can go and grab a drink i will be right
back
is it gonna watch the hulu or the hbo
max
version of the gen 3 documentary
i want the sex schneider
me too i only watched the hulu one
because i was told they actually
they actually like interviewed the
jackass that did it right
yeah way more info out of them they're
both
interesting for sure oh yeah like you
you watch it back to back and you get
new information from either oh man
everybody sees
that boost everyone
i know what i was thinking
someone needs to push me
this this this round can go to absolute
[ __ ]
so fast oh you guys are taking advantage
of my good nature to push things
okay oh damn damn it i'm so sad inside
i'm gonna go on the other side where no
one
oh no i'm sorry you're having connection
issues that sucks
[Music]
oh is this going to work no this is not
going to work we need a big boy over
here
we need a tall boy it's all boys
how tall
someone keeps saying that the walls are
slow lower
decreases yeah they slowly lower really
no i don't think
is this going to be final round barb i
thought you said bob
i've never made it to a final round
[Music]
[Music]
where do we put them you gotta put them
in your little castle in the basket
oh yeah yeah wait what's your fault
hey there you go the little uh barbara
what's your character name hey
hey hey you guys if you are in in the
color team please join the color channel
oh yeah i can't i can't i hear you on it
and i'm going to
y'all right now the money realizes but 7
seven dollars isn't it satisfying you
love to see yourself but also you love
to break it and raise twenty thousand
dollars instead
molly yeah twenty thousand would be cool
about it so
yeah yeah no three seven hundred seventy
eight dollars and seventy six months
time you know you can't just be grouping
with your buds you gotta get into the
team
well other people might be because
they're in the red team by themselves
so you know and blue team by themselves
you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
[Music]
being eliminated out here all right well
yeah
this is going to be close because red's
behind but this gold is going to put
them right back in it there you go yeah
i think so yeah blue's struggling
[Laughter]
looking blue's going out oh no it's just
nothing
yellow
have a mighty need to order something
to order but i was just going into red
team throwing out all their eggs
that was so good that was so cool final
round let's see
i feel good i feel hot i feel oh it's a
fun round
all right i got i got a group of andy
cortez here i'm not using this
yo what up i hate this one though you
feeling you feeling the pressure
i'm so hanky we got you in here too and
bri yeah bria you also in final round
i would like to join the channel to
listen to the shenanigans that's fair
that's bad
i don't know if you saw it i created a
little uh follow for follow thanks
people we can follow find yourself
see that very nice very nice cause it's
been uh it's been lovely
all right all right all right
are you in here liam yeah let's go it
was my second time
i'm definitely not winning i'm not i
need to bring this one back for gen 3.
matt i feel like you get to the end like
virtually every time
i get to the end and then i choke
because i'm because i
choked but
i know the game's well enough that i can
get to the end most of the time
well i believe in you bud i think this
is your dub you got it coming thank you
hey i thought you believe it was my dub
oh i haven't been there if it's one of
the three of us i'm happy
i believe it's your dub no i don't see
it i don't see it that way
i appreciate it but i don't see it that
way watching this one just gives me
anxiety i can't
i can't like yeah it's pretty so it's
unsettling
i learned the tactic from the person
that won this last time you just sort of
stay on them and then jump a little bit
oh yeah yeah has any oh two eliminations
already strategy for this level
it's kind of long i feel like you're
doing the right thing
so thank you you seem to be doing the
right i don't know
moves i guess i don't know i'm taking my
time
but i don't really know yeah i'm patient
you know i'm patient but anyway
you're sure gonna message the four guys
team and suggest that they
let you change your name in private
lobbies i think that would be so
typical a private lobby name
would be nice yeah because like for the
private lobbies what does it matter you
know
yeah yeah makes sense i feel like it
would be a good time only two hours
a bunch yeah this is where it gets
interesting i think
i like that you have a direct line to
the full guys people over the volvo
that's fun
i feel like i have direct lines to a
couple of people yeah
oh okay but i don't often have things to
request or this is like a thing that
they let me test which is awesome that
they're really really cool
who does p off of them he's incredible
oh wow nice
another elimination that it's almost
like even like it's almost flat
not a lot of second layers going on
anymore yeah
see i i feel like i'm i'm liking your
strat here matt i'm feeling it
i am liking what you're putting down i'm
trying to scope it out you know like
yeah yeah
yeah i go for that second tough one
maybe over there oh no oh there oh
everybody's up and everything
yeah yes good [ __ ] it's happening
it's gonna be a new winner too none of
these people have won before
i need it to be me just so we're clear
it's it's the three of you who are in
here everyone's dead
silent who's it gonna be is it gonna be
your green skull
is it gonna be your liam james right
you're trying so hard
oh my gosh this is intense oh wow
i've never done a jump like that before
that was a lot oh
the green skull's got a lot of ground a
lot of ground around in there
oh you made it oh is that you
let's go baby nice good nice
good kitten very good
it was a joke seven is gonna be a green
skull
he's the game that's what they're saying
that's what they say about him
have you seen him oh my gosh oh
that's that's close that was stupid i
had so
much room left too i was not scared did
you really oh
too late no no just kidding kidding just
kidding total kills
um okay i had a green skull
just follow me what's that about that oh
hey you're welcome
i also threw up uh i was enjoying our
chats um noticed i don't want to spread
the word i put up a follow for follow
uh chat channel and discord here so
everybody can kind of follow each other
because i've been very much enjoying it
where is andy cortez i'm trying to find
wherever he is he's in here somewhere
where the [ __ ] is andy cortez
i'm standing by the fact that i'll be
dropping 250 dollars into this if i can
somehow win
i was so close nice i was so close yeah
i need this i need this i've never won a
crown i have to have it i haven't seen
him
i haven't either i'm not competitive
enough i think is what happens i get to
the final round and i'm like
whatever it's maybe it's an australian
thing we just go
maybe somebody wants this more than me
well it's a tall puppy thing because if
you do win suddenly everybody hates then
you're evil
yeah oh that's that's definitely a thing
total puppy syndrome
fairly but not like uh i feel like i
should leave the final round as we now
enter the first round yeah yeah let's
jump out again
the egg she's the egg person yo what up
grabby egg
no what up she's a grabbie is
he's part of gen 3. he they they put a
hit out on us
that's what he's doing three spy in gen
two yeah
yeah well i think i think the crazy
thing is he was a green team first
and then he joined gen three really yeah
oh wow
oh my god
[Music]
oh
this is maybe like the third time i've
done this one it's it's a lot there's a
lot happening
just don't forget that the pink spikes
are the only things moving the platform
is not
but what about the blocks of donuts that
are spanking my butt
what about those those are moving oh big
monkeys
steve do you have tips for getting past
logs yeah they're just knocking me off
every time
you run and go and hug them
okay yeah the drawbridges are are kind
of a son of a [ __ ]
yeah okay okay i'm gonna call i'm gonna
call i'm hanging out i'm tricking him
who was the space astronaut that was a
loner that's me i'm not i think i'm the
only astronaut in the whole suburb
oh wow it looks like you're just
watching earth from above
yeah you're a space man because your ass
is out of this world
[Laughter]
wow something something uranus is that
too far
nice nice never too far steve
okay fam i'm out for the night it's been
so fun to hang out with you guys alana
this has been great
thanks thank you joey
have a good weekend see you next year
have a good weekend
i hope i see you next year i mean yeah
it's not have a good weekend
we're on a holiday break i like this
level it's the new slime climb for me
um
i think it's designer yeah slime climb
i'm pretty sure that legally classifies
you as a sociopath
so yes
i've never liked flashlights i feel like
if you like this one
immediately no no if you like the tail
when you're a furry
if you like slime blenders
that's right that's a lot all right
[Laughter]
a lot of discoveries tonight
learn something about myself i didn't
know
got some new things to explain
guys what do we do here when the boxing
gloves come around we stay patient
yeah with you patient patients every
virtue
patient wait walk oh i see you alone
it's hard when people are bonking into
look at us taking our time being patient
out here you see us being patient
i agree actually i think we were a
little bit too patient on the last one
yeah
but we're still out here
[Music]
keep happening
[Music]
if alana wins i'll donate 100 if not
i'll still donate well
that's
i'm basically robbing children by being
bad no
because anybody wins we'll donate a
hundred dollars
i am in it i am in it okay i'm going to
jump into that yeah
here we go again what is up my dudes
look all i'm saying okay
all i'm saying is people are saying if i
win
they're donating money so that's all i'm
saying okay
you should i mean we could all just jump
off the edge right but if you don't let
me win
you are taking you're basically a
horrible person if you guys jump off the
edge i'll jump off the edge
but we're not all in here so it's not
going to be consistent well that's the
problem
there are so many people in here yeah
why are there
busy ones yeah the biggest final round
don't worry
me and you all jump up let's
no no no no no
well that's the hundreds of the children
gone
i got eaten there's so many people
they're all always watching people oh my
god
you killed them like an idiot
karma i'm down
i can't believe there were some titans
in that round too that was oh
that was close i was right there yes if
your last name is
m-a-g-u-i-d correct correct
boom number eight a yusuf very nice work
good [ __ ]
no we have almost raised eight thousand
dollars that would be fun for me i would
really close to
yeah wait is that isn't that the hexagon
or you mean the one
earlier
your skill matters at some point wait
how what
sure so i don't ever have a strat for
hexagon how do you think your skill
matters for it
i think the so the strategy is just like
creating
any amount of separation even if you're
like kind of creating less jumps for
yourself
because other people are gonna fight
over all the other ones right so it's
like even if you can section off like
five or six jumps for yourself and then
create a little bit of separation so
you're above everybody
and then you kind of like plan your
route down to the bottom
there you go hello friend hello hello
hello
we need one short now what happened i
don't imagine we are it's probably just
somebody needs to know a couple of
people have left
for organizing this is awesome thanks
for joining it is really fun and i keep
i keep saying to my stream like i have
no idea if this is interesting
to watch because there are so many
people talking and naturally like
i know a lot of these people that i'm
talking to but the stream has no idea
who any of them are it's just so many
and like i don't know what this is like
to stream but i'm having a great friday
night so
yeah it also makes it weirder because
you're looking at someone in like
friendly muffin
and then you're just like trying to
commentate it's like turns out oh wait
that's spartacus
it's just like so it's just like a lot
less anticlimactic
i recognize most people's pictures
like so mark i wouldn't have guessed
that that
that that logo was yours but everyone
else in here i'm like well i know who
this is
like brie is obviously gonna be the
halos mika is literally a picture of
mika so he keeps a picture of soakie
like most of you i'm like okay i can
figure out for the picture
except for mock who's really just a
rogue agent in here
um today tonight has like reminded me of
like you know at convention parties
you're hopping around
yeah yeah that's nice we lost
three people all right let me figure out
what's happening here
all right all right all right is
everybody in are we losing people what's
happening
i'm heading off
uh are all of you in yeah yeah
oh yeah sorry we're in yeah yeah yeah
everyone is because we're missing
people now yeah we're talking we just
broke it
yeah plugs and whiskey
are you guys all in yeah all right i
think i'm gonna i'm gonna need to leave
the code this is what's gonna happen so
we get three more people oh
we
there we go it's not public that's crazy
that the code is 40gbi
are you going to leave the code the one
that says finally it wasn't me
i know that's the thing that's driving
me nuts is that why do you have o's and
zeros because the first code had a zero
in it
alana that came at me i didn't make it
i'm just i was just pointing something
out
can you go dave i can't believe you made
these comments
no i don't know what this font is it's
not a standard font
for a discord discord font no no no i
mean the code in the game
welcome pepe is here awesome you should
just be able to read fall guys
is that the name of the fun i should
study it yeah
oh did we did we just fill up that
quickly yeah
that is 40 people the only the only
better font than fall guy quan is impact
they don't make fonts like hey man i
like a good helvetica
i'm a fan of how that goes standard
that's a good fun man that's a good font
what about papyrus is
it's all about goddamn impact no other
font impact is used
i do also just like a regular old aerial
like it's a good grip
okay this is all you i am killing
the gentleman's phone see i don't ever
i know but i stopped using it i like i
feel like when i hit like 16 i was like
i'm an aerial woman
now the times new roman days of behind
me those are the plans i'm
and everything you say is now funny also
i i gotta say
weaving under the snowball is absolutely
the play yeah the snowball weave is
so really better i haven't been yeah
anyone use jokerman out there
any psycho real life psychopaths hey man
we live in a society that's all i'm
saying
is big news this one huge
okay the big news is go ahead keen
frantic baller
has succeeded in winning this mini game
nice
clap it up slap it up for our hero let's
slap it up for the fellow
friends incredible honestly incredible
teen frantic baller they don't build
gamers like me no more they don't
i'm just simply built that's what
they've been saying yeah i heard people
saying that i know
he's a gamer of the of the ages yeah i
know i call him
the people's gamer i honestly got the
game awards when i didn't win
every mini game yeah yeah every award
yeah we
all know you were also nominated and
lost yeah same
i nominated every award but yeah it was
for every award and i got robbed for all
of them yo hoarders
[Music]
it's my birthday
oh you're naked you're just hot you're
butt ass naked
you ain't wearing no clothes oh my gosh
i mean
i like i fight for the blue team oh i
like
all right i'm stealing pokeball
oh i'm doing everything i can to protect
two balls and no one
cares let's get it let's go i was i was
trying jacob but then i
i got distracted well good job on trying
braden
go take it yellow okay wait we got
another one we got another one
yellow get it here okay
[Music]
[Music]
what's the play here dave what are you
doing what is
going to do what's the point in need of
a major competition
that makes sense right a motto is
wow
that ball and it just barely crossed
over that
red team had the most people in their
call too rough
wait jacob you just invited me to play
how does yeah
i mean oh oh new game new game
yeah let's go play our own game while we
wait
i agree yeah yeah that's way more fun
hold on let me uh i think i need to back
out of
block party first almost done
oh kate's still alive yeah i was a
yellow boy
all right we trust we trust somebody in
my chat is talking about windings
uh we don't talk about women we do not
talk about
to be honest that's not even a font no
it's garbage
that's a joke what's the point of
wingdings by the way it's a [ __ ]
oh it's just funny because it's fun is
it wait is that a point bite me bro
yeah jacob you're gonna could you invite
me again please
nice snap yo what up we winning and then
nothing
yo welcome to the quiet elimination room
i
love a bit of time out you know just a
little bit of a time out never hurt
anybody
just hang out here with my
yeah that was actually pretty brutal
yeah you guys got sort of sweet there
how you been doing though you've been
getting through it i made it to the
final round
there you go i feel like you
specifically kept telling me that you're
terrible at this
i've been playing this for days and not
made it beyond the second round
especially in these winter games
yeah the winter games are a lot to
manage it's a lot
on the screen
to play winter whatever it is
it was um terrible because the second
game was always the ski slope game
and i would get eliminated but we've
only had that like once
the whole evening and i don't feel like
i think that's the secret zero curses
yeah
it'd be cool if like with the private
lobbies if i can eventually pick
what people are playing yeah i wonder
how
how extensive they'll get with it it'll
be neat
there's also been quite a nice lack of
ones that require multiple buttons like
the ones where you've got to like grab
grab and jump
at the same time yeah or my work and
then ledge one when you've got to move
the blocks
yeah anything that requires more than
one thing at a time it's too much
what kind of setup are you playing with
for this game
mouth and keyboards and luckily pogba is
created through them
eventually introduce remapping of the
mouse so i could pick what buttons on my
mouse do what
neat game yeah which is an accessibility
win
yeah for sure didn't originally start
with yeah so on them for listening to
our buddy steve spawn on that one i
think he's a good man that steve spawn
he's a good egg he's my friend me too
i think he might be one of my best
friends you know i feel like that might
have happened at some point it's like i
had this thought the other day i was
like talk to steve spawn
like almost every day i think we might
be like really good friends
but it's so weird because that happened
this year when we don't see each other
i i exactly the same thing yeah i have
met my best friend this year during the
day no way oh wow
that's cool that's actually really cool
yeah
so close yeah i mean
[Music]
oh awesome that's so neat cool congrats
i've almost said a hundred
yes queen
i wish there was a smarter way for me to
promote everyone but because there are
so many people in the server
because people have been like who are
you playing with can you give us a list
and i was like how would i compile a
list of 80 people like i don't know what
i'll see if i can because like obviously
i love like you know spreading the love
but i don't know
how i would do that yeah
everything i can figure away in the
world yelling out a couple new followers
from this too that's awesome
and i've actually stayed above 10 i got
like around 10
viewers now hell yeah you love to see it
yeah i feel like i picked people of like
wildly different sized audiences which
is also pretty cool um yeah
yeah for sure i'm like oh my god i'm in
a room with spartacus i'm talking to
spartacus
see that's funny because liam's a
[ __ ] dork
like you you you singling out liam is
like
spartacus um but i think like
you know people like uh i think that
some of the biggest stream is like
peaced out but
uh because it is absolute chaos but it's
a cool mix of people it's very
very nice for me having a bunch of
people i know in one place
yeah i think general too was was going
to be the death of me i think if i'd
stayed in general too too long i
wouldn't have been
can be very noisy out in here everyone's
nicely
getting
all right i'm going to jump into the
final round chat to
see how they do let's jump out there so
good right now that's my guy will let's
go out and get you a crown right now bro
mike are you here
i'm here alana pierce will is
let's go well i think this is your dub
i've been in the final round
five times
yeah you're looking good bro i see you
with that dope reindeer outfit you look
great friendly little muffin again
oh god you all get into this i couldn't
ask for a worthier opponent getting good
ah different type of
gary this one is my favorite favorite
i will gary the bringer of rick patrick
come on wait gary
this is my zone just so everybody knows
it's my zone i mean i don't i don't want
to mess with you you're
you're not going down tonight oh god oh
god
everybody just makes the jumps will all
five get crowns
timer where's this ready you can't timer
it but it's like five minutes long it's
inside of your heart
it's inside of your heart baby why is it
saying zero of four a little bit oh
well oh buddy no
no no now we all can't get crowns what
the hell wait why
why was this
i cannot believe you just did that to me
that whole round
well i only took it from you once then i
was just running away and then all of a
sudden
did you guys see that freeze yeah
there's really bad decent when you
spectate
yeah oh man who's hacking who's hacking
for character the text is also like
really frequently blurry
oh my gosh that was stressful i've got
names i've got aimbot on but it doesn't
seem to help in this one it's like when
you take that it looks like the bar is
hitting them every time but it's not
that's not what you're saying oh is that
really cause
it's like it's like nipping the feet but
i keep having like frame rate drops on
the
on the fall guys themselves weirdly
oh my gosh you guys neither of you guys
have won
oh my god oh my god oh my god it's brian
and liam it's brian and liam
oh no chum versus muffin oh one of these
is getting a crown
oh congrats yeah
[Music]
oh that's the closest i've ever got to
getting a crayon for my whole life
that felt good to you because that was
my last one i think yeah i think i think
most people wanted
thanks for stopping by congratulations
congrats
i think we probably
because we don't have enough people now
let me see let me see how everyone's
feeling
because i know other people said they
wanted to drop so unless you want to
draw unless you want to drop the code
into your chat and just
i have already done that we could just
keep doing that i guess let me just link
it again
um the last one i can drop it into mine
i'll do it
yeah feel free i'm just going to hit
start as soon as it's at 40 so that we
don't have
too many strangers all right
and while i'm doing that i'm going to
drop some money into this chair
yeah we're 8 600 i would love to see
this
let's put it up here get a bit higher
than that that would be very nice
using the paypal's let's go oh you're
doing it yourself thanks liam
also i have echo from
are you from gen 3 who me
from gen 3 no i've been i've been alone
all night so i thought i'd come by and
say happy holidays and listen to you
guys these incredible voices oh okay
we're definitely not talking [ __ ] about
the winner so yeah
okay there we go martin i know you you
be out here talking [ __ ] about winners
how many do we have i know what you're
about 40 yeah
it's 41. right now 40.
come on alana what if you do like 80
people among us make it happen i mean i
do know
them too i could probably talk to them
about stuff like this but
i don't know how that would go
every year i have for a while wanted to
figure out a way to do competitive among
us like a leaderboard kind of like
knockout
game type thing um yeah you know i think
i can probably figure out a way to do
that at some point
it would be so fun ah oh my god i'm
getting just owned by this
the fan yeah sometimes it do be like
that we need fans man
subscribe to my only fans the whirly gig
map i feel like that's a song that i
don't know
got easy call coming up yourself and you
say that every time gary
they can't all be easy questions always
yes they can that's the rule all calls
are easy
oh my gosh
because we do
all right
ah bye is that me i didn't want to say
we've hit eight thousand six hundred
dollars
nine thousand nine thousand nine
thousand would be cool but not
not yet we're pretty close though we can
make over nine thousand
that would be nice that's all i'm saying
raising money to end child
property so you know pretty pretty sick
cause if you want [ __ ] slime oh i
hate this one
i know somebody in my existence is
did you see gary sweater by the way you
wrote a film where everyone
basically died okay i don't know a lot
of people died okay gary
i don't need this in my life i mean a
lot of yeah a lot of people did die yeah
no body no more it's the sacrifice i'm
going to make
don't touch the slime so i have the
biggest problem with this this part
right here that i've just yep had a
problem with um what part are you on
the second part with the moving ones
that you have to jump between
i feel like i just get pushed off so
much
someone kept grabbing me as i was trying
to jump mike get off those tracks
mike you're like the only one in the
entire server who has been trolling
people
i've had to defend you i've been like
he's actually a really nice guy
he's a nice he's an angel i'm so sorry
that he's bullying
it's a jekyll and hyde thing with mike
though
fall guy brings out the world
like i said before this game does not
build character it reveals
you got a second shot at it oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh i'm gonna
coach alana here to the end
okay all right okay you're good you've
got plenty of time
do i take your time take your time
through the pushes here yeah
yeah there's only two people with twenty
dollars and i don't even know what i'm
getting [ __ ] knocked by
the issue
oh my god you gotta take your time
oh my god sometimes it do be like that
slime is right on you now oh you're
right like nobody's qualifying
yeah everybody's waiting at the end
people are waiting at the end he's gonna
get knocked oh my god wait wait wait
wait wait oh because it's the it's the
the big bonkers
[Music]
seven made it this is the final round
climb that one
how do you it doesn't have time for
yourself
look at that chaos i think you have to
time it and goes
oh yeah i think so yeah this would be a
final round
look at the gnomon that's the top right
the little furry guy with the
yellow beanie so cute nose top left
literal opposite direction top left
i was looking to cry i'm sorry the
pledge of a stray man
all right alana oh it's a full mountain
and another mountain classic
okay hang on i'm gonna be in fun around
okay you pitch me later you go damn
business man
a lot a lot of people backing you andy
don't [ __ ] this up oh jesus
my gentlemen big mistake big mistake
everybody huge mistake
he's he's maybe losing no evil
he's looking good he's looking good he's
solid he's solid
no mistakes yet plenty of time all right
here we go
he's going down that left channel
monster doing some strong okay okay
moves in there no no no no no no no no
no no oh andy you got to go with the
rotation at all
andy
you didn't technically get the crown see
i saw it yeah
two still two dubs first
but i'll probably hang out thanks for
joining i want to see
i want to if anyone watching hasn't
donated and you can afford to donate i
highly recommend well we hit see
out of nowhere we hit 9 000 and we're at
9 000. there you go
oh my god liam thank you so much for
your donation
[Music]
my mod patrick donated 100.
how did you become a muffin can i ask
that question uh
well we okay on chat one time when they
just released that thing where you could
name yourself
we went for like it's probably a solid
30 minutes and i was like i had better
names and i was like no
maybe you can do better and it's just
terrible right it's because
yeah yeah and they were just like it was
the popular vote they were like
you're picking the muffin oh you let
your chat pick your username
essentially yeah that's what happens i
respect that i i picked uh dreamy
sliding gal
because i could make a sexually new
window out of it so that's how my brain
i don't understand now
if you were wondering don't worry about
it i'll tell you i'll tell you when
you're older
oh okay maybe when you have kids slam um
then maybe
okay so yeah a couple of years yeah well
should i ask that
child of mine if he understands you
yeah he's like a solid one solid one it
means it's about a lady anyway
um he's a solid one yeah yeah
he's very small i definitely qualified
for final round i didn't get eliminated
first round
the i should update the chat and make
sure that they know that that's my bad
it's my bad
yeah you've you've misrepresented this i
really want to get on that board for no
reason i
just want to get on the board it's a
pretty impressive board yeah so we've
got the
real heroes real heroes steve zaragoza
snow bike mike snow bike mike steve
zaragoza
oh man yep and then we've got ouiji call
galleon green skull youssef
gubbegley and sohinki it's a
list of people we've got diversity up
there in the end
right like yeah that's true yeah we got
out of the steve snow bike snow bike
steve
eventually yeah vicious cycle stop
trying
no all right i'm gonna um i'm gonna call
it an evening
all right okay see you again thank you
so much alana for inviting me that was
really fun of course thanks for coming
by
everyone have a have a wonderful uh
holiday mm-hmm
you as well happy new year
good night bye good night everybody
lovely start show now that gary's gone
we're good to go
this eliminated chat here because it
seems to be popular what are we doing
over there
what's going on with the eliminated chat
hey you guys hanging out having a good
time
hey we're all here you guys are out here
vibing
look how cute welcome back five minutes
oh tiffany
it's so cute a guy named douglas is
delivering my whiskey in nine minutes
and i'm very excited
his name is no one delivering it douglas
oh
no i buy that a dude named douglas
delivers whiskey
100 and he's going to be like oh is this
a blessing i have got your whiskey for
you sir
it is master douglas
follow for follow chat i need to follow
i'm trying to get everybody
all right they're all fine don't worry
about it how are we waiting for someone
to follow her
there's a
oh follow-up god oh we did it we did it
we did it video game is happening
where's your damn twitter at in there
you know
nobody phone chat though like i really
wouldn't watch it
like a great time they basically make
like a bunch of trash content
and sometimes they make music
and it's actually pretty incredible and
i'm like amazed by all of your skills
okay
okay
wait what happened
this is the one we've done like a
billion times yeah
okay okay i'm undefeated
all the time so i'm very curious
yeah he was waxing his handlebar
don't smile back
and just give up i
[Music]
is that what you're telling me
on this list
and i'm so excited i'm very proud of it
look at all these i was too busy
following people
[Laughter]
let me promote the charity first modern
you monster the
um promote the charity the link for the
charity for you guys
uh is in the stream details section okay
so you can find it there if you would
like to share it
um i also put in the overlay we were
streaming
tonight that alana has reminded me that
i have not read stream details
hey all the info is in there but you
just gotta go to
stream details that you have yet to read
it okay
[Music]
oh my god so we actually um
we did try to make a show kind of like
this at rooster teeth but
um it was too expensive i think in part
because of insurance
um this show was fully pitched
um but it just couldn't happen [ __ ] off
oh my god come on [ __ ]
oh my god london
and then like goddammit nhs yeah
[Music]
we're doing our last stream on retro
replay tomorrow we're doing like
a good thing tomorrow so if he wants to
play some among us tomorrow just just
add me in
otherwise guys it's been a real pleasure
yeah yeah
you've been amazing thank you yeah yeah
see you bye
a lot of those so intense oh my god that
really [ __ ]
north oh yeah no that was yeah
so that was liam who uh you may know as
jd phoenix from the games of the world
franchise
he's also in spoticus
not nolan north that was throwing north
no
no no no no no no no that's awesome
[Music]
don't i don't know if it's the fact that
it's like
15 minutes to 5 00 a.m or it's the
tequila
that's what i'm saying
oh that's right we
it's funny because like people in my
house are going to be getting up for
work in a minute because they have work
this saturday
what the [ __ ] are you doing you know we
have hit
ten thousand dollars
thank you so much
a few hundred dollar donations for no no
please
should we jump into final round chat
should we do it anyway i don't know
who's in how many
everyone's just kind of in eliminated
lobby one right now i don't know what
um
just to see if it gave me luck it was
the opposite
yeah i have got further since i've just
chilled and eliminated
okay thank you those eliminated vibes
really help you out
yeah yeah so here we go
did you finally look at stream details
is that what happened you finally looked
at it
yeah i know it's really cute
i actually don't have a camera connected
look at these jiggly
just have done with springy one where's
your phone
that was that was fast oh
we're halfway there yeah all right i do
have to
i have to stop streaming at nine which
means the lobbies
will close i know i actually i actually
talk to them
it's cool yeah so yeah you can keep
streaming
i could give one of you my
login i could do that so if you guys
want to keep playing you can
i mean like i said it was okay well
connor you'd probably be the one that i
would give it to
um if you would want to do that
but that takes kind of reorganizing a
little bit
it's not like you guys can't continue to
hang out here
that doesn't happen as soon as you end
the game the whole dress code
everyone on twitter we're done it's the
most amount of social interaction i've
had all month i know isn't it
who is this cool singing kitten i don't
even think he's one of us come on matt's
gonna win it
come on we want amazing scarlet monster
to get the dub because i don't think
cool singing kitten is one of us
matt again nice
work i i really wanted you to get that
one because i think that that that
person was a random
i think that that was yeah someone else
who joined in so that's a double win for
you so hinky hell yeah dude nice um feel
free to come hang out in
eliminated chat because i guess that's
where everyone is now
okay you might wanna mika's just sitting
up in general one you might wanna
drag her down oh yeah i'll do that i'll
do that
do we have enough people to get into
this we can
this will be yeah remainder yeah um i
like the code remaining
three more and then this will be our
last one
ten thousand three hundred dollars i
don't think it's likely
we probably won't raise twenty 000 by
the end of the stream which means i
currently have like two active
fundraising campaigns that haven't hit
their goals yet so i got a lot of work
to do over the last couple weeks
but all i'm gonna say is if you could
even donate a
dollar during this last round uh it
literally is going to get rid of child
poverty so
you know it's a pretty good cause red
nose day is a pretty big deal um
please help out you put it that way that
really confused me because i was like
i was about to say don't donate a pound
and then you're like daughter and i'm
like oh yeah well actually
a pound is technically more valuable so
i can get on board with that
yeah i hope i have a i have a quick is
that it
is worth more yeah
yeah it was difficult
let's do banana grams next time as it
turns out
being a producer for five years worked
in my favor but it still was like a lot
more chaotic than
i was like i don't know
oh
he actually probably would have joined
us but he didn't
know he didn't he was never here
dude
it's almost like you're playing a
different game when nolan is like
yeah because you are because he's not
playing this again so
yeah he's playing you know he was never
here
so what point were we playing with nolan
north no no no
wow
that's the biggest donation oh thank you
so much that's true
amazing hell yeah thank you
i can't believe nolan north just donated
as well we don't want to take that away
from jerusalem
yeah all right we're not taking that
away from drew all right
he's amazing for dropping that sorry
um
apparently drew has donated like
thousands of dollars
wow at this point like multiple
donations well thank you so much
um again this is this is all for getting
rid of child poverty getting kids
education food clothes all that good
stuff so
that's so cool you [ __ ] love to see
this somebody that grew up homeless
i really appreciate that i think it's
ma'am
you know i feel like you mostly have to
thank red nose day not really me but um
i'm still out here doing my best
yeah solving get hungry can i just say
i'm so used to losing after the first
round i forgot that i was playing
[Laughter]
yes oh why did they introduce these fish
son of a [ __ ] save the children guys
save each other
for the children
pushing me i saw somebody on twitter
canceling santa today
yeah [ __ ] that guy he breaks into your
house and he eats your food no
[ __ ] that was
got
but he's also immortal so everyone's
like why you know what i mean
he could be a super spreader we don't
know we don't well he can get it
he can be in pain forever and just not
die yeah
that's pretty painful
not affiliated
yeah we absolutely did while holding
hands though it was quite nice
oh that was that's that's that's yeah i
don't know what else i would want to do
yeah
it was pretty sweet [ __ ] off there's too
many bananas this is i got just
just [ __ ] i don't like that kicked in
the back by a [ __ ] straw is that log
frozen i don't know
what's going on with that i don't know
either yeah yeah so fast i couldn't even
get up to the conveyor belt i was just
yeah i didn't have it i didn't even
know bananas in the face and i just said
really
i really enjoyed the nolan north but
it's really good
leave him alone
all that's left is for someone to hope
that he's on cameo and buy a cameo of
him being i had fun on a llama stream
[Laughter]
i mean i could just ask him i don't know
why we're making it so complicated and
we are hoping you guys don't don't be
done
don't be babies this early you all go to
[ __ ] you just gotta go for 70
i mean yeah i'm talking about the game
i'm talking about how everybody's
tiptoeing too carefully oh [ __ ] [ __ ] off
don't know about the stroller's drinking
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
i'm not a huge fan of babies if i'm
being completely honest
well it looks like you're doing a little
gaga in yourself
oh no what i'm doing is out here how's
your vlog
by the way guys can we try to make it to
12 000. come on guys
[Laughter]
see this
no stop oh my god i'm uncomfortable with
it because he's a friend and i feel like
he's gonna think we're [ __ ] talking him
and i don't like it
typically he's not a sensitive dude he'd
be fine i can't believe
justin timberlake was on the stream
that's fine yes go for it
that's completely fine i don't know who
mentioned the sliming
but i don't know if it's a show in the
states
or worse the show in the states it's
probably not going to be i feel like it
was a british
um it was called live and kicking and i
think i'm right
then i think they're a big surprise i
think it was a big deal
oh no oh i made a bad call i made a bad
call
the call was bad [ __ ] [ __ ] i recommend
like
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's been good you know you've been
right here we had 12 000 and someone
called nolan
[Applause]
it's not it's not actually nolan north
okay
it's not i'm gonna push it and if we hit
13
000 like i'm gonna just stay up for 24
hours at this point
you think he's willing to just join in
real quick
go back to justin timberlake
[Music]
we are joined by the ethereal bisexual
who are mostly black from barack obama's
past
[Music]
what are you [ __ ] pro gamers doing in
here oh we're trying to get the multi
crown oh there goes dupont
yeah i got i got knocked out because i
just jumped on a bad platform
i hate that a lot i know it was a huge
bummer
look at you go look at you go like i i
think i think wild
i don't think it should be you should be
singled out on an area right now it did
suck
great job oh my god okay is it youtube
it is youtube yeah we're going for the
double crown andy
come on okay so what do you have to do
what do you have to do we just have to
jump for five minutes straight the goal
is for me and andy to get a good
position here where we feel comfortable
enough okay
we're not going to bang into each other
like the other kid yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] hell we're all good because
there's latency on the on the like play
play playback uh it looks like
everyone's just screwed but you guys
doing isn't it the craziest
yeah you get that desync happening yeah
if this is too fast does it get faster
than this or does it just stay like this
uh this is probably max speed right here
this is where it's gonna work oh my
[ __ ] god
i'm so stressed for you guys but i would
like to see it
we're hoping for the double crown and
he's playing great great we're locked in
we have the alana pierce raising money
for a great cause having fun
oh my god also this is gonna be our last
game
another dub for the yeah this is the
last one
another dub for your boy snow bike mike
he is that is that is the most dubs for
snow bike mike
more so than anyone with three you beat
everyone
so i wanted to be alana you are
incredible you're always an inspiration
to me
happy holidays oh happy holidays of
course
thanks for joining that is the last game
man that gets the heart thomas
gg's y'all
great job everyone we raised man twelve
thousand
eight hundred dollars to charity i mean
i think it wouldn't be that hard
for us to like hit 13 right now is all
i'm saying chad everybody
bump it up right the hell now that was
incredible dude you know what i mean you
know
again chad shout out to alana for
organizing all of this
best thing must have been an absolute
headache it was
a bit tough yeah it wasn't super easy
but we did it absolutely
i mean a way to thank her for this
awesome fun content and a fun night of
y'all watching this stuff
go hit that link it's in yeah or you
already typed it in awesome [ __ ]
pretty cool go donate it'd be pretty
neat all right let me
hey what's up
obama is that you yeah
thank actually means a lot to the people
of the united states i don't understand
uh the question i'm sorry can you repeat
the question uh
it wasn't clear to me what you were
asking the guy's a jackass
mr president i don't mean to be uh rude
but i feel like your spotify playlist
was lacking this year
that's that's fair did we yeah
[Music]
that's amazing yeah
but you guys to stay in the discord for
as long as you would like
um but i have to go to bed i'm so tired
my husband made like homemade mech ribs
and it's really nice
what if we might as well make breakfast
at this point
in my ass so hard right now that's fast
good night everyone yeah
[Laughter]
all righty this is a super fun stream
thank you guys so much for joining
uh thank you for 13 dollars i wasn't
sure if we'd be able to make twenty but
all that means
is that i got two [ __ ] separate
charity campaigns
where we gotta make some money which i
have absolutely no problem with hang on
let me see how far the other one is
tilted five which is for feeding america
for the record let's
check the progress on my current
campaigns we are trying to make
another like 1 000 and something for
giving back
and then another 7 000 for thank miss
and i
will do it don't you worry about it
we'll uh we will do more streams to make
that money so
thank you guys so much for joining this
has been a super fun stream and um
i will see you guys next